you've assembled a number of essays from
anarchist thinkers in a new book called
the anarchist
handbook you uh mentioned emma goldman
what interesting things do these
thinkers agree on and what do they
disagree on
the anarchist handbook.com is the
website it covers from the 1790s to
i think my essay is the last one from
2014 which uh
a friend of mine who's uh kind of a
mediocre scientist is going to be
reading for the audiobook
um also podcasts and vodka i never
but it's not a podcast anyone would have
heard of it's like tom wood's been even
worse
so what they all agreed on
was the illegitimacy of government and
also
the malevolence of state actors and
the consequences of uh governments
so they range in terms that most people
would easily regard as either left or
right wing
but it tackles the nature of government
and
also creates positive non-state
alternatives
from really many different angles the
slogan i have is the black flag which is
the traditional flag of anarchism the
black flag comes in many colors
so they were really all over the map in
terms of what they're for
but their disagreement is about the
nature of state and the nature of power
and it's very edifying because this is
an ideology that's been
in many ways swept on the rug no one
takes this seriously grow up
um that i can allow people to sit down
and read these essays
and see for themselves just how
beautiful this tapestry
over the decades and centuries has been
woven about people who genuinely
believed
in freedom as the most important
and how to maximize that for society
you